Marcis in jacksonville florida hey Marci
how are you good how are you better than
I deserve what's up okay well thank you
for taking my call I am very thankful to
be talking to you I just have a question
I'm very deep goal driven to know that
by the end of November I want to have
this done by the beginning of the year
that done being with my circumstances on
my debt I'd like to know what you feel
is a good like goal line for me to set
for myself to be out of debt and then
also how far I can get being that I'm 53
years old and starting this a little bit
late are you single I am what's your
income thirty-nine five okay but I've
taken on a second job scrubbing toilets
okay and how much debt do you have not
counting your home that would be twenty
two thousand eight hundred and sixty
nine dollars mmm okay all right and so
11 five four two years
makes your debt free doesn't it yeah I
just do big math here it's all I know I
just took your 23 divided it by two and
I went 11-5 that's all I did so that's
two years that's pretty doable
let's thousand dollars a month you
probably could do it faster than that
because you're pretty motivated
goal-oriented and took on an extra job I
did and our weeks ago I did yeah
and so you see what I'm saying so I you
know you might do it in 18 months so all
we got to do then is just say 23 divided
by 3 is gonna be like 7,500 7800
something like that every six months
which puts us at about 1,300 1,200 a
month and you're done in 18 months um
long division like that okay and then
don't worry about calculating interest
and all that garbage and trying to get
it perfect I'm just looking at the big
numbers to kind of get my arms around
what's doable because nothing ever works
according to plan it either works faster
or slower than the plan
right and most of the time when people
are working this it works faster because
they get more fired up work more cut
deeper which creates more margin right
and the closer you get the more you can
sprint to the finish line you know and
so we're doing 1500 a month you might do
2,000 run that last month and boom you
know you bust through so the math quits
working the more excited you get and the
more you believe and that happens the
more you do it so I'm thinking a 12 to
18 months I'm sorry 18 to 24 months is
your number for debt free does that
logical to you yeah second the second
part of the question was I'm 53 I just
picked up your book six weeks ago I am a
super-intense about this but how far do
you think I can I mean I have nothing
save for retirement and I I need to so
unthinking retiring at 70 you think I
can have a pretty good message by then I
sure do so let's kind of put some
numbers in okay let's play with it all
right so you make 40,000 now assume that
you're not going to get any raises which
is a silly assumption but let's pretend
that you go from 55 years old with your
emergency fund in place to 70 that's 15
years okay mm-hmm and and we've been
paying off debt at the range of 1000 to
1500 a month and so let's just say that
you saved $1,000 a month
I'm just making up numbers here okay you
could do less or more right but let's
just put that in there and we're
starting with nothing and you have a
match on your 401 K I don't have a 401 K
available to you okay crack then you
would go into Roth IRA and into other
things to save money but if you did that
and you saved at a typical growth stock
mutual fund rate you would have around a
half a million dollars that's right okay
okay and you would be debt-free okay and
and so which by the way if that made 10%
a year 10% on 500,000 is 50,000
okay a year income without touching the
nest egg only taking only taking the
eggs from the goose not killing the
goose which means you would retire
making more money than you're making now
okay quite inspirational yeah you see
how we did it though it was very
realistic
I set a thousand dollars a month from
age fifty-five to age seventy invested
and that's in the more money you make
the more that realistic that is and the
more you could put in if you put in two
thousand you'd have a million if you put
in five hundred you're going to have two
hundred fifty thousand so here's the
thing if you'll work this plan like
we're talking about all the way out to
age 70 you're not going to be on Alpo we
just don't know whether you're going to
be on filet mignon okay
making sense yes yes it's exciting you
can do this you really can I'm excited
for you and you hold on I'm going to
send you a copy of Chris Hogan's book
retire inspired which is where you're
headed towards way to go kiddo proud of
you